[Dave:] I'm here with Jim Fruchterman who is the director of Benetech.
Tell us about what Benetech does.
[Jim:] Benetech is Silicon Valley's non-profit technology company,
and we exist to combat market failure.
Basically, when something doesn't make enough money but does a lot of social good,
we want to develop software that delivers solutions for that social problem.
[Dave:] What kinds of things do you actually build?
[Jim:] We write software in three different major areas.
The first one is education, especially for kids with disabilities.
Like we run the largest library for the print disabled, the blind, in the world online.
We also write software for the human rights movement, whether you're a grassroots group
or a truth commission or a war crimes tribunal.
Our third area is the environment.
We write project management software for environmentalists that are running campaigns
or managing programs on the ground to actually have the same kind of tools
you would have in a for-profit but because you're in the environment now you've got one.
[Dave:] And heard you're starting a new project for coding for social good.
[Jim:] Yeah, it's in a pilot phase right now.
It's called "Social Coding for Good," and you can kind of think of it as an
online matching site for geeks that want to do social good.
You tell us your passion, your technical skill, and your time availability,
and we'll hopefully match you up with a project like Wikimedia
or the Guardian Project helping human rights groups
or whatever other sort of project that matches up with your goals.
It's just in the pilot phase, but we're hoping that in the next year it goes to scale
so that geeks all over the world that want to do social good can get a chance
to go to a place like GitHub, do some volunteering, and get some good cred
for having done something socially good.
[Dave:] How much experience would students need to have to be able to start doing this?
[Jim:] Well, I think that people in different levels of the professional area
of software development can actually help.
I think our initial target audience is to work on people who are in the profession,
people who are working for high-tech companies or software developers,
but the human rights, the environment, and the education need people at
all sorts of different levels.
It could be characterizing a bug or writing some documentation,
and our goal, of course, is people can increase and improve their skills
by doing volunteering for social good, and then hopefully that leads to a job
either doing social good or maybe a regular job.
[Dave:] It sounds like you found ways to do lots of really beneficial things with technology.
Can you tell us what are the social responsibilities that someone who gets power
because they learned about technology should have?
[Jim:] You know, I think that being educated in a profession like software development
you have a responsibility to give back to society.
Many people do that by actually getting a job and creating products that have value.
The thing I want to talk to engineers is as you go out there and you see problems
that are important to society and they can take advantage or your skills,
don't ignore them just because they don't make a lot of money.
I think that there are ways to make a living or volunteer to actual help these issues,
and I think that that's really an area of terrific satisfaction as a toolmaker
when you see the great things that people do with your tools.
Solve bit social problems and actually find a way to change the world for the better,
not just for more money.